we're literally jumping into today
that's right okay yeah we're about to
get our bungee on and strapped in with
us as one of the funniest ladies on the
planet on the planet ever and the star
of the new romantic comedy at midnight
Whitney Cummings
I mean Whitney I am one of your biggest
girl crush fans like is that why you put
me in front of you that's why I thought
we should do a segment with love swings
have you ever tried a left swing have I
ever tried a love swing yeah what is
love
understood understood well we are going
to get on
from one love to the other yeah yeah
actually we're trying a hot new workout
uh Trend called bungee Fitness you look
super graceful thank you so much you're
welcome
here it is
[Applause]
an instructor from go
ghost it's Nikki cansler hi Nikki
[Applause]
we want to know this bungee craze this
is a real workout thing happening with
real health benefits right right okay
because right now I just feel I'm all up
in my bungee hole you know it's like oh
my goodness
um so what are the benefits of this
whole thing so Bungie is a low impact
high intensity workout and you can burn
anywhere from 350 to 800 calories in
just 45 minutes really yes yeah okay I
could also eat 800 in 45 minutes so I'm
excited to hear about the antidote to
all that okay well none of us have ever
done this before so we are in your home
address yes yes
bungee birthday yes this feels kind of
like the first time I wrote a horse and
I was like I like this
what do we do first what's our first
move all right so our first move is
going to be the plunge so basically you
want to stand with your feet about
shoulder width apart okay and imagine
that the front of your shoes are nailed
into the floor and you're really gonna
think about throwing yourself at the
floor your face I'll add a man that's
married
you're squeezing your core squeezing
your glutes and you're gonna throw
yourself squeeze squeeze squeeze to come
back up okay all right let's try it on
three we're gonna do it everyone ready
one two three oh my God
oh
[Applause]
that one's coming out that was good the
easiest way to get back up is to throw
yourself down harder the squeezing kind
of comes with it
it went down real hard
all right ready you're ready
count just in one two
there we go
okay
okay so we nailed step one what's step
two Nicky all right so next we have the
double Burpee so a little trickier it's
like a regular Burpee two times and what
you're doing is shooting your legs out
behind you with your knees straight okay
it's gonna look like this all right so
it's a squat
down squat down and back up yeah okay
all right down down back up okay okay
all right here we go one two three Squad
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to start a petition as Drew
Barrymore for the next Catwoman yeah
can't believe I used to be a Charlie's
Angel
it's like
you did by the way you used to be yeah
in my 20s don't Dash My Dreams Once An
Angel always an angel thank you
there's another move right we have one
more which is very similar so this one
is the drawbridge so basically we're
going to come all the way up as far as
we can you're going to turn drag your
feet and ideally you should be able to
stand up out of it Nikki that really is
basically what I've been doing this
whole time yes
three one two three
and then oh my God
[Applause]
it's actually really fun all right
I can't thank you enough for coming and
teaching us these beautiful moves if you
want to do this for real we will be
featuring Nikki and her workout and her
contact on our show website Instagram
and Tick Tock and Whitney is sticking
around because we're gonna hit some
headlines including figuring out what
his boyfriend error oh I don't know
memories
[Music]